I can't imagine how bold it is you're a
young director you've got John Travolta
and you're showing how to dance you're
teaching him how to dance I didn't have
to teach John Travolta how to dance I
wanted him to dance a particular way it
was a certain kind of I'll do it
[Music]
because it's a Twist now twists can be
kind of boring so part of the thing
about it is I wanted uh Vincent and Mia
I.E Uma Thurman to have two different
characters when they when they twist all
right when Vince twist I wanted him to
be kind of rich
but when Mia twists the image that I had
in my mind was the Zsa Gabor cat from
the Aristocats and there's that one
little scene where the Aristocats dance
and she kind of like
[Applause]
[Music]